hallo klickst du hallo Michael so
erstmal ein riesenloban ich Michelle du
bist echt Weltklasse und ich finde dann
wieder asozial geil die sind ja größte
Hammer und meine Oma allerdings auch
immer so wir sind zwei richtig
Konsistenz von dir
meine Frage an dich
magst du eigentlich alte Leute
so waren antwortete sich sehr freuen uns
bis dann
tolle Frage magst du eigentlich alte
Leute wurde ich gefragt ähm das ist
wirklich eine sehr sehr
wichtige Frage eigentlich denn ich finde
jeder von uns kann nur von Älteren etwas
lernen auch ich bin bin da immer sehr
aufgeschlossen und lernfähig ich habe
als 18-Jährige auch gedacht mir gehört
die Welt und ich habe das Wissen nach so
und so viele Jahren Schule jetzt
in mir und brauche nichts mehr dazu
lernen aber viel gedacht man lernt nie
aus und ich habe heute zum Beispiel über
was neues gelernt zum Beispiel ob Fische
seekrank werden können sie können
alter Schwede deswegen also es gibt so
viel Interessantes in dieser Welt und
ich glaube die Älteren die haben da
einfach mehr Lebenserfahrung und die
können uns jungen dann eben
dementsprechend sehr viel beibringen
deswegen
hört auf die alten